[Aplausos]
força e coragem
eu nasci no lado de mulheres fortes na
singular de mulheres que realizavam
planos
muitas vezes sem nada nas mãos força e
coragem eram as palavras que eu mais
ouvia minha casa tive a minha mãe sempre
como braço forte de casa empreendedor a
guerreira uma mulher cheia de fé de que
na vida e nunca achava que era
impossível as coisas que a gente queria
então quando eu falava para ela a mãe
queria tanto aquele tênis toda hora está
passando na propaganda ela falava nossa
muito legal também achei tão bonito
vamos pensar o que você pode fazer o que
a gente pode fazer juntas para comprar
ele foi lá e aí a gente pensar em que a
gente ia vender o que a gente vai fazer
o que a gente quer criar a ideia era
criar inventar fazer acontecer
eu lembro que um dos desafios maiores
que eu tive na adolescência foi ao show
do hollywood rock
eu queria conheceu a banda extreme e
skid row
eu falei mãe quero conhecer sebastião ba
quer conhecer o dono do extreme
ela falou nossa vai ser demais isso
vamos pensar o que a gente vai fazer
qual o seu plano que você tem nas mãos
essas eram as perguntas que mais tinha
no meu dia a dia
e foi aí que comecei empreender
aos 12 anos eu já vi em dia com a minha
mãe bolos na escola tortas lingerie
vasilhame de plástico e aos 12 anos eu
hoje formada em consumo em marketing aos
12 anos eu já conhecia o poder de
consumo da minha vizinhança já sabe o
tablet já sabia que eu podia vender para
cada uma e já tinha meus clientes fiéis
aliás
dona toninha dona maria da conceição
[Música]
obrigada essas foram as mulheres mais
fiéis às clientes mais cúmplices que eu
tive foram elas as vizinhas que mais
compravam os meus sonhos dos meus planos
eu batia lá do natelinha a gente fez um
bolo de chocolate
a senhora quer comprar minha filha não
entra aí vou comprar
elas eram as compras e quando a gente
tem cúmplices a gente tem tudo na vida
as pessoas que acreditam nos nossos
planos mas acima de tudo a gente precisa
acreditar então acreditar foi a palavra
que sempre me levou a lei
eu sempre sonhei em ser jornalista
e quando eu falava muitas pessoas que
conhecem a nossa realidade rio
mas eu sabia que tudo era possível minha
mãe me ensinou que eu conseguiria
realizar com que estivesse nas mãos
mesmo que tivesse muito pouco eu queria
ser jornalista
eu queria escrever histórias de mulheres
e de mulheres que faziam parte da minha
da minha vida que eu muitas vezes não
via nem ouvia histórias delas eu as via
vencedoras mas nas capas de revistas as
histórias de mulheres vencedoras que
houve nas revistas não eram elas que eu
queria contar aquelas histórias e aí eu
pergunto pra vocês
lá fora as crianças empreendem desde
pequenas
afora as crianças colocam uma uma banca
de de venda na porta de casa vender
limonada empreendem aprender a lidar com
o não aprender a lidar com o dinheiro
aprender a lidar com a criatividade a
inventar e as meninas da periferia que a
gente conhece essas meninas são
incentivadas
essas meninas são incentivados a criar
com que ela tem nas mãos
sem ter nada nas mãos
a gente tem muitas pesquisas e eu me
especializei em marketing de consumo de
mulheres
tem muita pesquisa que mostra a
realidade das meninas
as meninas da periferia as meninas pra
vocês terem uma idéia em uma pesquisa da
plena internacional que mostra que 65%
das meninas limpam a casa todos os dias
ao passo que apenas cerca de 11% dos
meninos homens fazem o mesmo
isso porque a gente já tem uma sociedade
que insiste em dizer que a menina tem
que limpar a casa que a responsabilidade
da menina tá errado ea urgente a gente
entender isso as nossas meninas estão
sendo colhidas colhidas por que não tem
nada nas mãos do lidas por serem da
periferia colhidas por terem que lidar
com o trabalho pesado estão sendo
incapacitadas de sonhar
as pesquisas mostram também que elas
sofrem violência e desigualdade de
gênero a todo momento em todo instante
eu precisava fazer alguma coisa com isso
com essa com esses estudos com essas
pesquisas afinal eu sou uma menina de
comunidades de periferia e eu cheguei em
espaços que eu sabia que era o meu por
direito e muitas vezes foi teimosa
muitas vezes eu entrava no espaço porque
eu acreditava e ouvir o som da minha mãe
falando que você quer fazer aqui que
você tem na mão vamos fazer acontecer e
eu dava meus passos 1 a 1 porque eu
acreditava que eu queria fazer isso com
outras meninas final me formei
jornalista trabalhou em grandes empresas
conseguir o meu espaço ao sol não podia
deixar de olhar pra trás e saber da onde
eu vim
então eu saí resolvi saída do mundo de
globais tinha empresas e resolvi criar o
meu plano o plano feminino um projeto
que da representatividade e conta
histórias de mulheres comuns inspiram
então no feminino
eu podia contar a história das mulheres
anônimas que não estava em capas de
revistas no plano feminino podia contar
a história do nosso fia história dona
maria
e de muitas outras que vem conhecendo na
minha trajetória
mas a prioridade era representatividade
diversidade
sobretudo não alienação no plano
feminino eu não queria falar para as
mulheres que elas tinham que tomar dez
litros de azeite por dia para ficar com
a barriga sequinha nem que ela tinha que
ter o cabelo xpto para serem as mais
bonitas
nem que o look do dia tinha que ser da
marca no plano feminino a gente conta a
história de mulheres reais
eu pesquisei durante seis anos o consumo
de informação de mulheres na internet e
as mulheres e alienam por conta de tanta
informação inútil de tanta coisa que
enfim nossa cabeça
você tem que ter você tem que consumir
você tem que ser no plano feminino a
gente não tinha isso a gente não tem
eu resolvi nesses seis anos voltar para
a comunidade
eu resolvi que além de criar propostas
para marcas que quisessem falar com a
mulher de uma forma mais honesta que
traz trouxessem representatividade para
publicidade
eu deveria voltar de onde eu vim e
conversar com as meninas que eu fui um
dia fala pra ela gente eu conheço o
caminho vamos lá vamos ocupar esses
espaços me incomodava ainda está agora
na ilha de manhattan que eu considero
onde o mais trabalho na vila olímpia
estar ali e não vê nenhuma dá nenhuma
mulher da minha cor nenhuma mulher da
minha raça nas mesas de reuniões nos
lugares que eu estava
então eu voltei pra conversar com essas
meninas mas antes disso antes de voltar
eu não seria nada se não tivesse mais
cúmplices e eu acreditei mais uma vez e
fui bater na porta de mulheres incríveis
que acolheram o projeto plano de menina
uma delas a consulesa da frança gente
uma menina de periferia tinha aberto
próprio negócio
e tinha uma consciência da frança como
embaixadora de um projeto e eu posso
conquistar o que for na minha vida nunca
vou esquecer de onde eu nasci e eu
sempre me emociono com essas conquistas
e além da consulesa da frança eu tinha
juízo as promotoras jornalistas
publicitários empreendedoras
eu tinha muitas amigas cúmplices de um
plano e mulheres que fui conhecendo
nessa trajetória de acreditar
mulheres que não viveram a mesma
situação que eu a maioria delas não
viveram mulheres que tinham trajetória
extremamente diferentes mas que a gente
tinha um propósito em comum o amor por
gente e transformação
a gente queria transformar o futuro das
mulheres
essas meninas
quando a gente chegou juntas na
comunidade e fez pesquisas conversas
workshop elas não tinham planos a gente
fazia perguntas algumas perguntas nem
tão de brincadeira com seu plano não
conversava e voltava para casa bem
triste sim às vezes até chorava porque
eu queria que elas contassem dos planos
e até ela não falava
seis meses depois o projeto com aulas de
autoestima empreendedorismo jornalismo
política direitos jornalismo
essas meninas tem muitos planos
se vocês perguntarem para qualquer uma
delas e muitas estão aqui hoje vocês vão
ouvir que elas querem voar e que elas
vão ocupar os espaços que são delas por
direito
elas vão estar ali com planos realizados
em pesquisas que mostram que o efeito de
uma garota empoderada para um país é de
milhões no pib outras pesquisas mostram
também que essas meninas são
responsáveis pela transformação do mundo
eu acredito e a gente está junto à
fazenda essa transformação e crescendo
nós e elas
ter um plano é o primeiro passo para se
ter protagonismo na vida
quando a gente tem um plano a gente
começa a avançar em direção a ele e as
meninas do plano de menina tem muitos
planos
elas vão alcançar o protagonismo delas
eu tenho certeza disso ela já estão
fazendo isso mas existem muitas outras
meninas
a gente precisa alcançar mais meninas eu
não quero só mudará publicidade
eu não quero só trazer
representatividade para as campanhas e
para as marcas ganharem mais dinheiro
isso é só parte do meu trabalho eu quero
fazer mais
eu quero desafiar vocês aqui cada um de
vocês pensem uma menina que vocês
conhecem
pensem o que vocês podem fazer por essas
meninas se cada um de nós
consegui mentor a uma menina
a gente vai ajudar na transformação
desse mundo
a gente vai ajudar mulheres
protagonistas mulheres que sim vão ser
melhor representados em todos
universitários em todas as esferas da
sociedade
eu acredito que a gente junto pode
empoderar muito mais meninas eu acredito
hoje eu tô aqui sou prova viva disso e
tenho certeza que o plano de uma menina
pode mudar o mundo
obrigada
[Aplausos]